gaulois réfractaires ces gens qui ne
sont rien
fainéant cynique analphabètes
emmanuel macron n'a eu de cesse que de
diviser de fracturer et même de dresser
les français les uns contre les autres
allant même jusqu'à déclarer cette
semaine que certains français qui
pourtant en enfreignent aucune loi
n'était plus des citoyens
je le dis le rôle d'un président c'est
d'emmener les français ce n'est pas de
les emmerder c'est de les considérer pas
de les déchoir de leur citoyenneté
qui fera vivre la france sinon son
peuple et quand on n'aime pas
profondément le peuple peut-on vraiment
aimer la france
oui je la firme je serai la présidente
du respect celle du respect des lois
parce que il n'y a pas de respect sans
autorité mais aussi celle du respect de
chacun d'entre nous y compris les plus
fragiles
ma philosophie est clair
présidente de la république je serai
ferme mais bienveillante
ferme et même intransigeante envers ceux
qui défient nos lois et qui à
l'intérieur comme au delà de nos
frontières
non que pour objectif le désordre de
s'en prendre à la nation et à la
république à leur égard comme je lé
déclaré jeudi je serai sans pitié
mais je serai en revanche bienveillante
à l'égard de l'immense majorité des vies
de nos concitoyens qu'ils respectent les
lois et qui défendent nos valeurs malgré
toutes nos différences
malgré tout nos désaccords
un président ne doit jamais être
inutilement condescendant ni blessant
au fond
emmanuel macron et dur avec les faibles
et faible avec les forts
c'est tout le contraire de ce que doit
être une présidente juste
j'incarnerai une présidence des
convictions
le en même temps véritable adn de cette
présidence restera comme une succession
de marche avant et marche arrière
donnant le tournis à chaque français nos
concitoyens sont épuisés parce zigzag
permanent nourrit depuis cinq années au
cynisme absolu et qui n'aura eu qu'une
seule conséquence
l'inefficacité le surplace
de manière constante et cohérente
je défendrai un projet d'espoir dit vise
à restaurer la confiance et à rendre sa
fierté à chaque français
mes mots d'ordre sont l'autorité la
liberté et la dignité
l'autorité pour ramener l'ordre dans la
rue à nos frontières et dans nos comptes
la liberté pour redonner de l'air à la
société
de l'air aux français en des
bureaucrates ''sans l'état et aux
remplaçants la précaution excessive par
le principe d'innovation
la dignité enfin pour réparer recoudre
les fractures augmenter les salaires et
les retraites et donner à chaque enfant
de france sa chance à travers le projet
de nation éducative qui refondre à
l'école républicaine
je le dis donc solennellement il est
temps de mettre un terme à cette
présidence de la discorde et du mépris
après tant d'immobilisme je savais que
je devrais réparer la france mais face à
tant de cynisme je m'aperçois que je
dois aussi relevé la fonction
présidentielle
alors transmettre à nos enfants une
france forte prospère unis respecté
partout dans le monde ce n'est pas un
slogan pour moi c'est une obligation
c'est une exigence
c'est un devoir et j'y consacrerai
toutes mes forces nous y consacrerons
toutes nos forces